لقد تحدثنا منذ أسابيع مع
خبراء الصحة العقلية الذين
حذروا من أن العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية في الخطوط الأمامية
سيكافحون بلا شك
ضغوط ما بعد الصدمة التي تتعامل مع هذا
الوباء لسنوات ، والآن
تعلمنا من أحد كبار أطباء غرفة الطوارئ في مانهاتن
الذي كرسها
الحياة لإنقاذ الآخرين الذين انتحروا يوم
الأحد بعد العمل على الخطوط
الأمامية لهذا الوباء المروع الدكتورة لورنا بريم
التي عملت في
مركز إيرفينغ الطبي بجامعة كولومبيا في
نظام مستشفى نيويورك برسبيتيريان
كانت تعالج مرضى
فيروس كورونا في قلب  مركز
هذا الوباء في جميع أنحاء العالم ، أخبرت برييني
والدها أن زملائها كانوا يعملون
لمدة 18 ساعة في اليوم وكانوا ينامون في
الممرات وكانوا يحاولون
رعاية تدفق مرضى كوفات 19
ووصفت كيف تم إبعاد سيارات الإسعاف
في المستشفى لأن
كانت المستشفى بكامل طاقتها ،
أصيبت الدكتورة برين نفسها بفيروس كورونا بعد أن
عملت بلا كلل في الطوارئ
لقد استغرقت أسبوعًا ونصف الأسبوع فقط
قبل أن تعود إلى العمل للمساعدة في إنقاذ
الآخرين بينما لا تزال تكافح الأعراض ،
تم إدخال د. برين إلى المستشفى
وعلاجها من الإرهاق بعد أيام ، ثم انتحرت وأطلق
عليها والدها فيليب لقب البطل
قائلاً  اقتباس ، نزلت في
الخنادق وقتلها العدو على
خط المواجهة كانت تحب نيويورك
ولن تسمع عن العيش في أي مكان آخر
كانت تحب زملائها في العمل وفعلت ما في
وسعها من أجلهم.
ذكرى برين نعمة
وتذكير بالإجهاد والصدمة
التي يعاني منها جميع الأبطال الطبيين الذين
يقاتلون ضد فيروس كورونا الذي
سيحتاجون إلى العناية بهم أيضًا